when the Babylon be reported that
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortez
had appeared on The Price is Right
guessing that everything presented by
host Drew Carey including world-class
health care cost nothing at all the
prominent online fact-checking site
Snopes assured readers that this didn't
actually occur it labeled the story
false along with Democrats demand that
Brett Kavanaugh submit to DNA tests to
prove he's not actually Hitler and CNN
purchases industrial sized washing
machine to spend news before publication
and a fact check and say no you know we
checked the record seeing and didn't buy
a washing machine recently you know and
so that was kind of bizarre it does seem
like they fact-check are ones that they
target the left more often
Kyle Mann is the editor in chief of the
Christian satirical news site which has
surged in popularity boasting about 10
million monthly page views just three
years after its founding
we don't necessarily target one side
over the other or we don't and we don't
necessarily strive for balance we look
to target whoever's being ridiculous
you know on a given day it's plenty to
go around and there's money to go around
on both sides Snopes defense for
fact-checking satire is that a lot of
people are misled by it and that they're
just trying to help people strengthen
their media literacy skills do you see
that as legitimate and has that been
consistent with your experience with
Snopes we don't necessarily disagree
with the idea of someone saying hey
we're gonna fact-check a joke you know
we're gonna fact-check this piece
because yeah sometimes there's a lot of
people out there that don't recognize
satire the real concern is that when we
start looking at you know who is the
fact checker like who are these people
that are supposed to be these objective
fact checkers you know and it's really
concerning when someone sets themselves
up and they say whenever we say
something is true you know we slap this
green true label on it or we say it's
false and we slapped this red false
label and how do we know that that's
accurate you know and we've seen
ideological bias from Snopes in the past
after Georgia lawmaker Erika Thomas
retracted her claim that someone had
told her to go back to her country the
be published an article poking fun at
the incident again Snopes accused man
and his colleagues of publishing fake
news
we didn't made a joke saying that she
went to chick-fil-a and the the
chick-fil-a worker says my pleasure you
know and she says oh he told me to go
back to my country and we're known for
chick-fil-a jokes like that's one of our
main things that we go back to they
filed us under the category junk nudes
and said that we were trying to fan the
flames of controversy and the ironic
thing was they didn't even fact-check
Erica Thomas's original claim but they
fact check I joke about it yeah so
that's when we start to be concerned
about some kind of slant or bias
man says that by mischaracterizing the
B's content Snopes could have a negative
impact on its traffic in revenue we've
been threatened with D monetization and
D platforming from Facebook when they
had a relationship with Snopes for fat
checking so that's kind of concerning
when a lot of these social media sites
are looking at how to squash fake news
and if we start to get lumped in with
sites that are actually sharing fake
news then it could be a big problem for
our platform and how we reach people
Snopes which didn't respond to reasons
interview requests has said that a
significant percentage of social media
users mistake satire for real news but
man says that when making this claim
Snoke decided a methodologically flawed
study in which participants were showed
Babylon B headlines reworded and taken
out of context a lot of times they
missed the joke entirely
they didn't even accurately represent
what our joke was trying to say and and
just did a very literal interpretation
of it and in that context I can
understand why a lot of people her to
see although the babylon b is primarily
concerned with making its readers laugh
man says that the site has a more
serious mission to uncovering truth you
can take satire and you can use it to
divide you can cut away what we believe
is true or what believe is important
from what's not important and we see
that in satire of politics so we see
that in satire of of religion you know
specifically when we when we do satire
about the modern church we do satire
about Christian living you know we can
take a lot of these these sacred cows
that Christians have set up and just
skewer oh you know and obviously a lot
of people don't appreciate that but we
feel like it's a great web and it's a
great tool to kind of separate what's
important from what's not whether that's
politics or our Christianity man says
that while Snopes is wrong to treat the
Babylon be as a serious news source the
satirical site does seek to help readers
better understand the real world I'd
like to say that the satire is not truth
but it's like truth adjacent so you're
creating this alternate world you're
creating this alternate reality it's
almost a mirror that holds up this
reflection of our world and we can help
draw people's world views and opinions
to a logical conclusion and then some
people can look at a look at that and
maybe say well you know maybe my ideas
do need to be thought out a little bit
more and sometimes not you know
sometimes people will just get a good
laugh out of it and that's ok with us
too
[Music]